unterwegs im tiefsten sibirien auf
meiner reise zum entzug lerne ich alexej
kennen er fährt taxi und hat zu allem
eine klare meinung auch zum thema corona
dass ich von der impfung halte ich werde
mich niemals impfen lassen
warum nicht weil das für das volk einen
langsamen tod bedeutet man will uns
bürger ausrotten nicht nur uns russen
sondern alle menschen
wir brauchen nahrung und getränke und so
weiter uns braucht man nicht die da oben
die werden gebraucht
alexej tritt auf wie der könig der
verschwörungstheoretiker
vielleicht steht das goldene krönchen
auf dem amaturenbrett dafür
ich höre ihn genau zu denn das was er
sagt hört man in russland nicht selten
wer dahinter steckt nun unsere führung
angefangen bei putin sieben personen
stecken dahinter konkret kann diese
nicht alle aufzählen aber da waren trump
und putin
sibirien russland zweites wunder
atemberaubend weit und ziemlich weit weg
von allem von informationen und von
impfstoffen im bahnhof von teils steht
eine antwort russlands auf die pandemie
der medizin zug der den impfstoff in die
provinz bringt sputnik wie bitte nehmen
sie doch platz wie es denn name
grammatur war gut
es dauert nur eine sekunde
ein pieks babuschka weiß jetzt muss sie
endlich keine angst mehr haben
warum haben sie sich impfen lassen weil
es die elbstadt gibt wimmer und viele
andere sind froh dass der zug nach
thailand gekommen ist bitte gehen sie
zur registrierung
hier in der abgeschiedenheit gibt es
wenig medizinische versorgung wenig
impfstoff die ärzte im zu kämpfen alle
die das wollen und die nicht im
krankenhaus behandelt werden menschen
also die hinter corona keine
weltverschwörung sehen wie stanislaw
wissen sie es gibt so viele gerüchte
viele wollen sich nicht in feldes
persönlich wollte sofort geimpft werden
wenn schon soviele menschen im ausland
unseren impfstoff wollen die sind doch
nicht alle dumm
das heißt doch etwas
sputnik wie im ausland auch in
deutschland gefragt in russland spaltet
er die gesellschaft gerade mal 6,5
prozent der russinnen sind geimpft das
sind rund 9,4 millionen von rund 145
millionen einwohnern
die einen halten die impfung für eine
segnung andere für teufelszeug
man muss weg vom zug um zu verstehen wie
sehr corona auch in russland polarisiert
stanislaw lebt mit seiner frau valentina
in einem dorf ganz in der nähe ich
begleite ihn dorthin er züchtet hühner
das beruhigt ihn die ganze situation
nämlich regt ihn auf 40 jahre lang waren
sie ein herz und eine seele haben alles
zusammen gemacht auch sport im
wohnzimmer jetzt ist dann is love
michael witt offiziell der einzige
geimpfte im dorf ich habe eben meine
eigene meinung er denkt anders
unterschiedliche überzeugungen haben wir
als ich damals beim zug war und die
erste impfung habe machen lassen
ja da waren wir zusammen aber ich habe
mir gedacht ich habe hier immer so
schreckliche nebenwirkungen von
impfungen und wer wird dann die
renovierung des elternhauses fertig
machen
das mache ich nämlich alleine 1000
gründe sich nicht impfen zu lassen hat
valentina ihr hobby die stickerei seine
diät das renovierungsbedürftige
elternhaus valentina immerhin weiß
corona ist ernst
meine schwester ist im november
gestorben man hat uns gesagt an krone
aber sie hatte doch hunderte andere
krankheiten
man hat sie begraben aber wir durften
nicht dabei sein
es gibt die die keine impfung wollen und
die die keine impfung haben können aus
vielerlei gründen der impf zu kind hat
mäßigen zulauf auf der ganzen strecke
haben sie gerade einmal 2.000 menschen
geimpft
wir fahren ins dorf nias 40 kilometer
vom zug entfernt
ludmilla kosova stellt uns stühle bereit
setzen sie sich
sie lebt hier so abgeschieden wie man in
sibirien nur leben kann kein arzt kaum
geschäfte kein öffentlicher nahverkehr
sie würde sich impfen lassen sagt sie
aber für sie sind selbst die 40
kilometer nach teils unüberwindbar ich
komme nirgendwohin ich muss begleitet
werden brauche ein auto muss 1 mieten
ich gehe nirgendwo hin ludmilla war 40
jahre lang lehrerin geschichte ein
bisschen merkt man dass auch heute noch
das schlimmste an der situation sagt sie
sei dass menschen wie sie halt wenig
mobil krank auf der strecke blieben
in wien seien wir uns den wänden warum
werden wir nicht geimpft sie haben den
lehrern an der schule etwas impfstoff
gegeben aber zu wenig die bevölkerung
ist nicht geimpft und die leute werden
krank
sie fühlt sich allein gelassen mit der
situation hier in ihrem häuschen am
rande der welt ich steige noch einmal zu
alexej ins taxi er bleibt bei seiner
sicht der dinge
corona verschwörung mächtigen
verschwörung und überhaupt sei das ende
nah und dann im internet ich weiß nicht
ob das stimmt ob sie da lügen aber man
schreibt dort nach der impfung lebt der
mensch noch ein jahr und dann ist
schluss
es gibt sie auch im tiefsten sibirien
verschwörungstheoretiker wie alexej
menschen die händeringend auf eine
impfung warten und menschen die einfach
nicht geimpft werden können
der zug in teilt übrigens ist am abend
weitergefahren nächste station niewels
geyer weiter durch russlands wilde ferne